[Music]
the world is getting closer to achieving
one of the most important public health
goals of our time eradicating HIV and to
do this we won't even have to cure the
disease we simply have to stop HIV from
being transmitted until eventually it
fizzles out once this goal would have
seemed impossible HIV has caused
millions of deaths and is one of the
most devastating diseases that humanity
has ever known but we're now at a point
where new advances such as one pill once
a day medications are helping us tackle
HIV in effective ways HIV is a
retrovirus meaning it integrates copies
of itself into an infected cells DNA
allowing it to replicate and infect
other cells HIV has evolved numerous
ways to Eve aid the human immune system
which makes it difficult to cure but by
developing ways to block HIV replication
we can stop the spread of HIV itself
that's where anti retrovirals aka ARVs
come in they RVs are a group of drugs
which work in different ways to combat
HIV some block HIV s access into immune
cells and others work by stopping the
virus itself from replicating a RV's
also work preventatively in people who
don't have HIV this type of approach is
called pre exposure prophylaxis or prep
prep works by accumulating in a person's
body and preventing HIV from
establishing itself that means an HIV
negative person who may be at risk of
contracting the disease can take certain
ARVs to protect themselves before they
become exposed here's where it gets
especially interesting in people with
HIV ARVs can also dramatically reduce
HIV transmission this is called
treatment as prevention on a global
scale this has the potential to end the
HIV epidemic
it's based on the idea that someone with
HIV who takes ARVs can lower the virus
level in their bodies until it becomes
undetectable that doesn't mean the virus
is gone it could still be lurking within
cells ready to reactivate if treatment
stops but so long as it's kept dormant
with drugs HIV remains undetectable and
when HIV is undetectable its
untranslatable - in theory this means
that by testing everyone who's at risk
of HIV and treating those who test
positive we could stop transmission and
eventually eradicate HIV in the real
world however things are more complex
many at-risk HIV negative people across
the world
do not have access to prep or ARVs and
those who are HIV positive may
experience challenges to taking a RV's
these problems are often greatest in
countries where the burden of HIV is
highest getting these medications
depends on access to a functioning
healthcare system and this isn't
something everyone has that's part of
the reason why stopping the spread of
HIV for good will require a significant
investment of resources to improve those
systems one study carried out by UN aids
estimated that between twenty to thirty
billion dollars per year would be needed
to achieve a nearly 90 percent reduction
in new HIV infections by 2030 this
investment would ensure more people
would get tested in the first place and
more would be able to access and
maintain treatment achieving this goal
and improving healthcare in general is
in everyone's best interest from
individual people to society as a whole
we have roadmaps that could allow us to
bring the HIV epidemic to an end
in the near future with the possibility
of eradicating the disease altogether
several generations in the future in the
period from 1996 to 2017 we almost have
two the number of new HIV infections and
for the millions of people who still
live with the virus ARV treatments
enable most to lead long and healthy
lives with continued and increased
investments we can get transmission
rates low enough to end HIV once and for
all
a world without HIV is no longer
inconceivable it's closer than ever the
progress we've made in treating and
preventing HIV is incredible but that
doesn't mean we should stop searching
for a cure learn more about the
challenges of curing HIV in this lesson
[Music]